what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into secret Empire this
is man this quickly shaped up to be one
of my absolute favorite stories that
really that I've read in Marvel Comics
for quite some time I absolutely love it
but there are a lot of you guys here who
are new a lot of you guys who probably
don't know about all the controversy is
kind of surrounding it so what I want to
do is sort of explain this a little bit
because there are a lot of people who
have been looking around and asking why
are people so upset about what's going
on with secret Empire for a lot of
people it's not really secret Empire
that they're upset about it's the idea
of Marvel as a whole what people look at
with Marvel is they get angry and they
say okay Jane Foster is now for in Odin
Sun is just a guy wielding an enchanted
axe riri Williams is now Iron Man and
Tony Stark is just in stasis and this is
AI that's basically running around
everywhere people look at these changes
and they're basically saying I'm not
being given a choice I'm not being asked
do I want to read for Odin's son or Jane
Foster Thor I'm being told if you want
to read Thor you're reading Jane Foster
people aren't being asked do you want to
read Bruce Banner Incredible Hulk or do
you want to read Amadeus Cho Incredible
whole live being told if you're reading
hope you're reading on a day as touhou
that's the biggest issue that people
have they feel like they're being forced
into a situations they don't want to be
in and if people have the option of
either reading something they enjoy or
reading something they don't enjoy don't
choose what they enjoy but if what they
enjoy isn't available
they won't choose anything and they'll
walk away and that's the biggest issue
that people are facing with right now so
secret Empire initially opens up with
the most logical thing which is m dot
Renee ting tits and that's one of the
interesting scenarios here is because
when it comes to taking over any one
particular country it's all about
indoctrination it's all about going to
people I'm saying hey take this as an
absolute fact and do not ask why again
it's one of these things that you kind
of see and that's the purpose of it
being in here is to create relatability
but to also show us how far it can go
because in order for society to be
successful there has to be critical
thinking there have to be people who say
but why though like that that has to
happen that always needs to take place
because someone asking why leave
somebody else to say well here's the
answer and if they give them an answer
that requires critical thinking then the
question becomes well then how did you
arrive at that answer and that leads
them to the whole investigative process
and that leads into more questions being
asked and it leads to the idea of people
just not accepting something as absolute
truth and actually asking questions
about why things are the way they are
and that's really one
the things that I enjoyed most about
this little segment is it's basically
this notion of you can't take something
as an absolute truth because what had
happened is once Hydra took over Hydra
eliminated all forms of text that they
didn't agree with that was another
aspect of totalitarian and fascist
fascist policies if you disagree with a
book burn it but in the end they weren't
really just burning a book they were
burning the ideology of critical
thinking they were burning the ideology
of saying I don't agree with this but I
also have to accept that their opinions
out there different from my own it's
more or less kind of purporting this
idea of anybody who doesn't think the
way that I do is wrong and so again
that's why this is so significant is
because that's effectively what Hydra is
doing hydras religions kind of coming
along and saying okay guys look like we
now we're in the show which means that
kids read the books that we tell them to
read teachers teach what we tell them to
teach the news reports what we tell it
to report it's very much a totalitarian
regime dissent differing opinions people
who don't see the world the same way
that Hydra does all those people are
ousted either they're ostracized by
society or they're eliminated in their
entirety so again it's one of these
scenarios where it's a very slippery
slope the fact remains there's actually
one of the kids in this class who
reports on an inhuman reports on things
like the older brother of one of these
kids and basically saying look I saw him
doing something kind of weird only only
for us to find out that you know this
kid's brother had basically swallowed a
Captain America lunchbox in order to get
it for his younger brother and then was
basically sought after by the by the
cops you know more or less for Hydra
Society now again this is designed to
show us how bad things have gotten you
know just because of the fact that in
this particular scenario Inhumans are
immediately arrested if they haven't
registered themselves and that's kind of
an interesting scenario because again
it's creating this idea of individuals
who effectively intern and it makes a
lot of people uncomfortable because what
some people are sort of forced to do
assuming that they actually choose to
read the story is they're kind of forced
to realize that there are uncomfortable
truths out there but the idea isn't to
ignore uncomfortable truths
the idea is to embrace them and ask why
do they make me uncomfortable in the
first place again really feeding into
this idea of critical thinking feeding
into this idea of maybe I should just
ask why as opposed to just kind of
accepting things as an absolute truth
and so one of the other aspects on this
is the idea of the superhero suit is
kind of left out in space keep in mind
when Captain America initially launched
his campaign and began the process of
taking over the United States
shield that Carol Danvers had worked on
the shield that was designed to keep
threats outside of Earth was enacted
Captain Marvel and a handful of other
people out there who were you know
super-powered beings were basically
forced outside of the shield now
remember the reason why this happens is
because it would not have done earth any
good if they were like hey here's this
shield that can protect our planet from
everything except for like really
powerful people because the really
powerful things that are out there are
the ones that you worry about you
worried about Galactus you worry about
that you're worried about gladiator and
the Shiar Empire trying to obliterate
the whole of humanity this shield is
designed to keep out some of the most
powerful beings in existence and so
there's really no hope for Carol Danvers
or any of their guys to actually get
back onto earth proper so that means
that Hyperion it means that blue Marvel
it means that Carol Danvers yourself it
means that a lot of these characters who
were out there trying to stem off this
tide of Chitauri forces that are
constantly invading earth or at least
constantly trying to invade earth in
order to get their queen will ultimately
lead to then presumably die in combat
now one of the questions that has to be
asked here this is one of the things
that kind of stood out to me is that if
this shield is capable of keeping out
some of the most powerful beings in the
world and the Chitauri are a race of
aliens akin to insects without any
insane powers whatsoever
then why don't the forces of Carol
Danvers and those guys just leave go get
help somewhere what the Chitauri forces
constantly just bombard themselves onto
the shield and are inevitably killed
each and every time in truth it's just
Nick Spencer keeping them there it's
just a way for writer Nick Spencer to
say hey look we're keeping them around
we want them around here presumably for
this great big huge grand pooh-bah
conflict that takes place at the end of
everything and so from this point what
we do is we actually pick up with a kid
named Mary Sean and we actually join the
champions now what can we keep in mind
and this is why this is really kind of
cool is because of the fact that this is
designed to show us or at least give us
an indication that the superheroes are
really on the run I mean there's really
no hope now we'll find out how hopeless
a lot of them perceive things to be here
in a little while but at the moment you
know where this kid you know ready Shawn
is basically rescued by the champion so
by Miles Morales and by viv the daughter
of vision and by you know Amadeus Cho
Hulk and so on and so forth where he's
whisked away we actually pick up in
Denver with some giant monster that's
you know wreaking havoc now this is not
anything new and really we're not even
giving the origin of this monster and we
don't have to worry about it this is one
of those things where next Spencer kind
of plays it fast and loose with the
old-school Marvel style storytelling and
what I mean by
it's back during the 1960's in the early
1970s back when Marvel was coming out
with a lot of new superheroes you really
didn't see a lot of big crossover
conflict a conference event like you do
now instead with the wait Stanley and a
lot of the earlier earlier writers Roy
Thomas and you know Jerry Conway and
Steve Englehart the way they used to
write those stories back then is while
they weren't the most lighthearted there
were a lot light harder than they are
now and so you would see you know
Captain America facing off and fighting
off against like the snake monster or
you would see four against like the
molten man you know we're something
along those lines but you wouldn't see
like these great big huge grandiose
things and so it's really kind of
hitting at this idea that there's still
various threats out there the difference
is how they're dealt with when it came
to the traditional landscape of Avengers
they wouldn't normally obliterate these
things sometimes they would if the
monster just couldn't be reasoned with
if it was like a you know very primal
intelligence they couldn't understand
speech patterns or anything like that or
if it was just such a violent being that
there was no way to delay to defeat it
outside of killing it then sure they
would fall to that level but for the
most part it was always like contained
capture and then folded prisoner in this
instance that doesn't happen instead the
Hydra Avengers jump in and just kill the
thing now one of the things that I want
to address here are some of the members
of the Avengers the Deadpool is
straightforward it's all about cash when
it comes to superior spider-man I guess
the return of superior spider-man it's
more or less just the idea of you know
being on the devil's right hand and it's
past the same thing with you know with
with the Odin's son now there is a
little bit more to Odin son then we'll
actually find out we'll really get
around to issue number four or five and
we'll actually find out there's a lot
going on with his character that we're
not being made aware of remember Scarlet
Witch has been corrupted although we
don't we don't know how yet released we
don't know how an issue number one it is
number four we find out and we can spoil
this a little bit I mean it's really
greatly huge revelation it's literally
just like a one panel thing that shows
us but with a Scarlet Witch she's
basically been corrupted by a demon main
c'thun and cthe own was the being they
gave her her powers in the first place
or at least I guess established a lot of
the abilities that she's currently
capable of the problem with this was
that with the character of Scarlet Witch
it was always this ongoing battle to
keep c'thun at Bank much the same way
that Doctor Strange tries to keep like
Dormammu
at bay the issue is that we don't really
know how but somewhere along the line
the scarlet witch's ability to fight off
the essence of c'thun was basically
hampered or eliminated in its entirety
and cotone has totally
taken over the body of Scarlet Witch so
in truth while this is Scarlet Witch
it's not really Wanda Maximoff
controlling her it's Capone control half
controlling her which this is actually
kind of cool because what it does is it
creates a Redemption element for Wanda
Maximoff herself which could actually
tell some pretty compelling stories at
the same time you know these guys are
basically rounded up pretty fast realms
are where they defeat this monster
pretty fast what we do is we actually
pick up with this pretty interesting
revelation in the sense that while there
is a lot of fascist things taking place
the idea that Inhumans are rounded up if
they refuse to register there's also the
idea that the country's better off than
it was before
and again this kind of creates a little
bit of a lost corollary in the sense
that can a country really be better off
under a totalitarian regime and the
answer is yes it actually can countries
are nothing more than a byproduct of
people who own power and the people who
try to keep that power from corrupting
everything the people versus a super
rich that's how you want to call it but
the idea here is that with a singular
person or council running the show
restricting freedom from everybody
then the emphasis or the issue doesn't
necessarily become people will have the
free will to like buy homes they can't
afford and things like that instead they
will walk where we tell them to they
will do what we tell them to or at least
a large enough majority will do you
don't really have to worry about it and
then from there it's a matter of now how
do we keep them under control and that
is the genius of this it would've been
very easy for Captain America and his
forces to implement this policy where
they're just like tanks in the streets
every day top station outside people's
houses and they follow them everywhere
they go but they don't do that instead
what they do is they say what we need is
to give people a reason to want us to
stay it's not enough for us to take over
we have to give a little reason to cheer
for us and so why eliminating monsters
by creating shovel-ready jobs and
improving the employment levels by
creating a more stable economy that's
how they keep people there by creating
these peace accords by bringing bringing
conflict to an end between the United
States and various other territories
that are out there that's how all that
ends up happening they basically say
look we've made the country almost
infinitely better and so ultimately it
all is up coming down on the shoulders
of the people what are you willing to
sacrifice in order to make the world a
better place are you willing to give up
your freedom to make the country better
for a lot of people the answer's no you
asking that question and without a
second guess the answer is no absolutely
not the debated refused to give that up
and their minds you know into the minds
of a lot of people it's I'd rather live
in a priest
that destroys itself using its own
freedom then have a long life in a
totalitarian society because what
happens when that council that does
everything to Bennett that society as a
whole becomes a council that decides to
tear society down they become evil they
become corrupted they become crooked
well then suddenly we have no choice we
don't have the ability to do anything
and that's the argument they make
because while things are down and out in
a free society well they're not
necessarily the greatest thing ever the
freedom that that society has allows
them to make it better
that's the difference is that ultimately
it all comes down on the shoulders of
the people and what they're willing to
do and how they're willing to make
things work in order to make them better
I mean this civil rights movement happen
to a degree with regards to government
regulation in terms of new laws being
passed and so on and so forth but it
wasn't soldiers in the streets marching
on behalf of African Americans and
multiple cultures that were out there
instead it was the American people that
were marching out on the streets it was
the American people making their voices
heard when it comes to you know the
whole idea of like we know Marvel's
shift to bring back a lot of the older
characters that people wanted to see
returned it was a government policy that
made that happen it was people who were
saying I'm not going to read what you're
putting out until you bring back the
characters and I want to see it's
ultimately the people that make those
things happen and so that's one of the
other benefits of the stories because it
shows us that at the end of the day it
all comes down on the shoulders of
people doing the right thing or doing
what they believe to be right to make
society a better place that ultimately
keeps it better for the long haul
so again it's really kind of a cool
scenario here one of the other things
that really hits on here is the idea of
what's going on with the x-ring we're
really told here is that there's a sort
of treating which green Hydra and the
x-men in a sense of the x-men are given
their own autonomy they're given their
own section of the country where no
one's allowed to affect them you know
it's one of those you stay away I stay
away kind of things and that makes sense
when it comes to like Marvel Comics the
bottles really been given like the x-men
kind of a crap end of the stick and so
it's one way to kind of you know smooth
things over with regards to the fan base
in terms of like okay let's you guys
don't want the Inhumans we won't really
give you the Inhumans and we won't
punish the x-men for being the x-men
we're not going to make them like the
butt of all the heinous experiences of
Hydra instead we'll just have them kind
of often no-man's land within the realm
of novel comics some of the most
powerful beings that exist on the face
of the planet are mutants and so I mean
if you're Hydra and you're running the
show do you really want somebody who can
work reality spray it all up for you
do you really want to piss off a guy who
can transmit matter on the atomic scale
just by looking at it is that really a
guy that you want against you or is that
a guy that you want either neutral or on
your side and so again it just kind of
makes good sense with regards to the to
the role that Hydra is taking but with
regards to the whole idea of you know
the traditional superheroes themselves
or the Avengers as we normally think of
them what we end up doing is of course
you pick up with Rayshawn the champions
once they arrive back at the old
Avengers or I guess the new avengers
headquarters kind of this old abandoned
bunker where Hydra wouldn't really look
for them or anything like that but we
end up finding out the things are
actually pretty bad like things are on
the pretty down-and-out just because of
the fact that Rayshawn actually shows up
alongside the champions who have just
kind of made us grab this kid and then
just brought him over but once he says
looks you know I have some information
that was handed to me by a guy by the
name of Rick Jones don't really know who
he is but he told me to give it to you
guys because you could win the war the
Avengers
send him off to meet Tony Stark now the
reason why is because of the fact that
remember Rick Jones was the guy who
leaked all the information about Azov
hill the scenario where shield was using
a cosmic you to manipulate the reality
around it and trick all the villains
into thinking that they were kind of
living in this idyllic paradise and so
because of the fact that Rick Jones
basically forced into shield custody
after the event of Pleasant Hill in any
Landru of serving a prison sentence he
was able to gain access to all kinds of
information especially after Hydra had
taken over shield and the United States
and so what are you done if he had
grabbed all these little bits and pieces
of information consolidated them into a
single thumb drive gave it to raeshawn
and then sit Rishon on his way to go
meet the Avengers and so during its
conversation with Tony Stark it's
actually kind of an interesting scenario
because Tony Stark's usually always the
futurist like the idealist he's always
thinking one step ahead or two steps
ahead or 20 steps ahead or something
like that but in this instance Tony
Stark has basically given up now the
reason why this was kind of cool is
because there's always been this sort of
antithesis between Tony Stark and
Captain America they represent begins
and yang's they're always opposites and
it has been since civil wars Civil War
for Captain America and Iron Man was the
Dark Knight Returns for Batman and
Superman
it was the seminal story that basically
established that they're always going to
bump heads forever they're never going
to agree on anything in an absolute way
and so much like the original age of
Ultron story where Ultron I basically
taken over the world
and Captain America had effectively
given up until he come on you know until
they came up with an idea to go find one
of Nick Fury
Bunker's tony stark's much the same way
he's like look we can't fight man all we
can do is just hide we can just live
from one day to the next do the best we
can and then just call it quits you know
I'll just go on for as long as we can
until Hydra catches us or something
along those lines and so again it's kind
of the interesting scenario because what
it tells us is that while some people
have given up others haven't then the
reason why is because of the fact that
we end up learning that with this whole
scenario of Steve Rogers more or less
being a Hydra agent during a meeting or
I guess a dinner that he has with Sharon
Carter there's still a little bit of
humanity left in it and that's one of
the reasons why this is so interesting
is because when it comes to Captain
America he's not wholly evil right like
he's not inherently evil I guess I am
like Vlad the Impaler and I'm just going
to like kill everybody or something like
that you know it's nothing along those
lines
for him it's really more about the idea
of he genuinely thinks that he's doing
the right thing he genuinely believes
that he's actually making the making the
country a better place which in a lot of
ways he is - those individuals who were
being you know tortured or executed it's
the whole idea of he's genuinely trying
to make the country a better place and
so because of that what he ends up doing
or at least when he's talking to Sharon
Carter's of course is basically told us
that Rick Jones had been captured
following his leaking of all this
information - to Rayshawn which
eventually made his way to the Avengers
and an attempt to demonstrate that he
still does Steve Rogers that Sharon
Carter knows or at least in the sense
that he still has some shred of humanity
she actually asked him to let Rick Jones
live to basically spare his life because
remember he is basically on in sentence
for execution he's going to be killed
and so the coolest thing about this
actually comes directly from Rick Jones
himself and the reason why is because
he's the guy who just will not give up
Captain America gives them an option and
says look all you have to do is say hail
Hydra that's all you have to do all you
have to do is just say hail Hydra and
you'll go free now this seems like a
small thing right like it seems like a
tiny little thing like all you have to
do is say hail Hydra but it's the idea
behind it it's everything that it stands
for saying hail Hydra means he'll Hodge
it's a couple of words the words in and
of themselves don't necessarily mean
anything it's the meaning behind them
that has all the significance if Rick
Jones says hail Hydra then it means that
he's effectively given up that he said
okay look I guess Hydra really has one
but so long as he does not say hail
Hydra it means that Hydra can be
defeated there's at least one person out
there even if he's moments away from
being killed who still
hydras not right who still believe that
Hydra can fall not only that because of
the fact that a lot of people are aware
that Rick Jones basically leaked all
this information out regarding Pleasant
Hill that he's the one that basically it
was able to obtain the information and
send it over to to the Avengers the
Avengers themselves now see him is
something of a martyr and so where he's
told all you have to be was say hail
Hydra and you'll live instead he
responds Avengers Assemble and the
reason why this is so important is
because of the fact that now he's a
martyr now he's a he's the cost now it
if we do this we got to do it for Rick
Jones and the other people like him his
name will always come up he's going to
be a champion of the rebel effort in
order to overthrow a Hydra property so
that's why this is so interesting and so
ultimately we pick up with Madame Hydra
herself again the reason why is because
of the fact that we're actually gonna
learn there's a lot more about her then
is initially depicted here but she was
the one that had come along when Steve
Rogers was a little kid and recruited
him into Hydra in the first place
alongside his mom and so the question
are the issue that Captain America faces
right now is from one hand with regards
to Rick Jones he's doing what needs to
be done but on the other hand
Rick Jones stands for something much
larger he's little rebel excursion these
little attempts to tear down Hydra these
guerrilla warfare tactics all stemmed
from the idea that there are still
people out there who believe that Hydra
is wrong that Hydra can be taken down
and so when is it happening as this
inner circle you know crack in dr.
Foster's hive
Arnim Zola these different guys all
basically say the only thing that we can
do here is we've got to crack down even
harder we've got to make things even
tougher we have to show them that if
they cross us that we are going to
execute them we're going to destroy
everything they know and love and so
Captain America is kind of torn here
just because of the fact that if he
gives in to Hydra to the Hydra Council
and says yes you're right it makes them
look weak
but if he doesn't give in then it makes
it look like he's weak on you know
people who were basically being rebels
it's a no-win situation and so
ultimately what he does if he takes his
hand out of the equation and its
entirety
he gives the authority to Madame Hydra
to Eliza to basically go through and
implement the ad that's going to show
the strength of Hydra in the face of
those who would attempt to challenge
hydras leadership and so with the
Avengers all gather outside of Las Vegas
to see what in the world's going on
Hydra emerges with their massive
warships and begins leveling the entire
city they destroy the entirety of Las
Vegas Nevada
but what happening said guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob Court you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later please
[Music]
you